i've told a few stories already about
cats that have been an important part of
my life including
sassy who's still around with us at 19
years old and the two kittens that i i
raised little boy and little girl
uh who lived to be about
12 or 13. and today i'm going to tell
you about another cat who i didn't own
who wasn't part of my household except
for a short time but who was kind of an
important fixture in my life
and his name was cricket and he belonged
to my grandpa and my grandma on my mom's
side who had recently at that time about
five years before built their retirement
homes
in northwestern indiana where my family
still has these houses
and uh land you know shayla marie's is
is what the sign reads as you come in
and that's from my mother's side of the
family
and
if we go back to 1980 when i was uh just
10 years old
my mother had had an operation
and was recovering from it so we decided
instead of having her travel
she and my dad decided to host the
family christmas the lumbery's family
christmas of our branch of the lemarese
family the ama bibian and also hubert
and and tori's branch um out at our
house and you know my mom and dad about
five years before that had
bought land
and had built a house
in the hills of delafield which is a
subdivision at that time like totally
uninhabited we were like the second
family to move in and
the lots didn't move for a long time so
it was it was basically countryside for
quite a long time close to the village
of wales
and by that time
you know there there were quite a few
families in there and we had a lot of
space i remember sleeping
up in my mom and dad's room on the floor
while all the family was there because
somebody had my bedroom for their branch
of the family and when i say branch of
the family so there's my grandfather and
grandmother amae and bibian lemreese who
by the way were
my uncle eubert my grandfather's brother
married
uh therese my grandmother's sister so
two brothers and two sisters who
actually had houses side by side
connected by a garage
uncle hubert and aunt honey that's what
we called antares
were you know childless but they were
always like a second pair of
grandparents so
my mom had two brothers and one sister
and the one brother
uh aim uh had you know been divorced and
and his uh child wasn't in the picture
anymore at that point although she's
since become you know connected to the
family but uncle john and aunt mary my
mother's brother and sister-in-law and
aunt bibian and uncle scott they had
kids
so
um there were all of us there and then
of course my dad's father my grandpa joe
or
grandpa sadler was also living with us
and spending a lot of time in the
basement which we'd furnished
now
there's a back story as well about cats
so
my uncle aim at that time lived with my
grandfather and grandmother in a
little
basement room that he'd furnished
himself he was a great carpenter he had
an entire wood shop down there
and
anyway he um
you know he had a cat that came along
with him named captain midnight
captain midnight unfortunately died out
on county line road within a couple
months of being there
so they got another cat who
was named cricket
that cat unfortunately died
in 1980 and grandpa and grandma were
kind of unhappy and wanted to have
another cat so my mom and dad got
together and they said well let's let's
give them a kitten for for christmas
and
they went they you know it was easy
enough to find somebody who had kittens
available and we were a bit worried
because at that time we also had a
pretty big dog her name was lady and my
dad had picked her out but she was
really like my dog
and
lady was a black lab german shepherd mix
about
70 pounds so pretty big and what was
going to happen when we brought this
little kitten in there which we did
about a month before you know so already
in november we we had this this little
kitten
it was pretty amazing
lady and this kitten would snuggle
together
and play together lady would actually
pick up a rag and shake it in front of
this tiny kitten's face and then the
kitten would chase her around the
basement or upstairs and you know the
kitten would laboriously make its way up
the stairs and then you know crawl
around and explore the entire place and
so cricket was a pretty cool cat lady
also used to play this game with a
kitten where the kitten would crawl
inside of a paper bag
i'm not sure where the paper bags came
from and would rustle the bag a little
bit and then lady would stick its nose
in there then the kitten would attack
her muzzle and the kitten you know had
some pretty sharp little claws but lady
didn't didn't mind and the one thing
that was even the best that now that i
remember it we in the basement we had a
couch
and you know it had a back like couches
do and the kitten would get up on top of
the couch and then crouch down so lady
couldn't see it and lady would walk by
the couch and the kitten would jump on
her back like right on her shoulders
and grab onto her neck and then lady
would run around with this kitten
clinging to her as if the kitten was
riding her like a cowboy riding a bowl
or something like that until the kitten
would eventually fall off and then
they'd you know hang out together and do
that
so in any case you know the kitten
adjusted very well and then you know the
whole family came
and i don't think we put the kitten
inside a bag or anything
but we said hey grandpa here is your new
cat and then grandpa immediately named
the cat cricket so this is cricket two
and that's you know i guess
they they just thought they'd recycle
the name or something like that
and so you know grandpa and grandma and
antony and uncle hubert they all stayed
with us i think about a week or so
my you know my two grandpas like to hang
out together and so they they'd sit in
the basement grandpa sadler would sit in
his chair
uh grandpa lamries would sit in in
another chair or on the couch and they'd
watch tv together and smoke cigarettes
and shoot the [ __ ] and drink beer and
you know all of that sort of stuff and
in any case
they took the little kitten home with
them and he became cricket
and grandpa
he liked the cat a lot and the cat would
follow him around when he went hunting
and you know he'd shoot rabbits and and
the cat would you know follow him and
and uh
cricket himself was was a great hunter
over time as well we saw him sometimes
carrying all sorts of things around
but grandpa didn't like cricket to come
inside i think he had the idea that cats
are supposed to be outside creatures
and you know back in that time before
global warming in in you know the 80s it
was actually pretty cool down in the
winters in indiana and so cricket um he
was allowed to come into the basement
occasionally to warm up by the wood
stove grandma would sometimes let him in
but then grandpa would often like put
him outside in the garage
and he had a box on one side of the
garage and a box on the other side of
the garage
where he would crawl up on and he could
you know cuddle up in some blankets or
towels or stuff like that
and
i would stay there a lot you know from
my
uh
pre-teen years all the way through my
teen years and then into my 20s
i spent a lot of time there sometimes
large portions of the summer
and a lot of family vacations you know
christmas easter
breaks we would spend down there in
indiana i think in part because it was
it was cheap right to hang out with
relatives
and sometimes you know when my dad was
still alive and then afterwards when it
was just my mom i think they would put
me down there basically so that they
could get some you know alone time
as adults
my sister would get sent to chicago
frequently to stay with my uncle john
and aunt mary but i would stay with uh
grandpa and grandma or uncle eubert and
antony or with my
aunt bib and uncle scott and
cricket was an important part of that
i'd see him wandering around i'd called
him and he'd come over and i'd you know
scratch him and he'd he was cool with
that and sometimes we'd play a little
bit
but he was very independent and
one of the things that i i remember
in particular that i really liked about
him was when i would come home at
christmas
and we would have our
um big
christmas eve
thing which was a giant dinner where we
would make all of our
family dishes you know tutsi which is a
canadian meat pie
and uh
you know there'd always be a man
sometimes it would be my grandpa
sometimes uncle john sometimes i'd do it
making the oyster soup and there were
all sorts of other things the boosted
noel
so we'd we'd get together and we'd hang
out and sing christmas songs and have
this great feast and then we would have
on christmas eve the
opening of the presents and go upstairs
in tonka hubert and antony's place and
which is also where we had the meal
and um
you know open the presents and stuff
like that and back then you know in in
my teen years and my 20s i was a smoker
and so we would we would go outside to
smoke and so that meant going out into
the garage and we'd often you know be
drinking beer as well while we're doing
that
and cricket would often be there and so
i'd i'd hang out with cricket
and you know um you know have a
cigarette and pet him and talk to him a
bit and he'd you know curl up next to me
and push with his head he was a giant
cat by the way he got pretty big his
head was like about this big around
and towards the end of his life
when i was uh in college um so i'm in my
my early 20s and i would go down there
he had these fangs that were really long
his cats get old their fangs get longer
and longer and male cats especially get
quite long fangs that just stuck out of
his mouth and he'd rub up against me and
those fangs would you know poke into my
hand and stuff like that and it was
really nice because uh
he was something that i i looked forward
to every time that i would visit to get
to see cricket
and of course you know
outside cats don't tend to live as long
as inside cats cricket was not an inside
outside cat he was mostly outside and
then you know staying in the garage as
his place
and he basically just ate whatever
kibble they served him and whatever
animals he killed and wanted to to you
know to gnaw on
so his diet i'm sure was not the best
and they i don't think they ever took
him to a vet you know my grandpa wasn't
going to shell out money for that so
it's probably
kind of a miracle he lived as long as he
did
and he was just a cool cat you know very
very much a cat's cat you could say
a lot of instinct a lot of
seeking comfort and friendship among
those who would give it to him
and uh yeah i really i really enjoyed
him it's been a very long time
you know more than 25 years since i've
seen him so more than half of my life
but i i still fondly remember him
and especially this time of the year
when it's you know the christmas holiday
and
i would you know as a kid as a teenager
as a young adult be down there
in indiana
spending time reading you know uh by the
wood stove or playing outside and and
seeing him you know [ __ ] around in the
snow
and then coming inside to hang out with
him in the garage where it was it was
pretty cold but it wasn't outside cold
and petting and petting him and spending
time with him you know
he was a really
nice fixture and i remember him in these
stages from being a little tiny kitten
playing with our dog
all the way to being you know a
kittenish cat to growing and becoming
big and strong and going out and hunting
and ranging around as i'd walk the
trails sometimes i'd run into him or
he'd follow me along along the trails
and you know wanting to hang out with me
so
that's just my reminisces reminiscences
of this cool cat cricket that
entered our life
around christmas time and
one of those christmases is the last
time that i i saw him
you